jean de gliniasty merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors en france
d'ici je parle d'une cérémonie
d'investiture en toute discrétion en
catimini d'alexandre loukachenko
pourtant quand on voit les images on va
le sentiment d'un rendez vous plutôt
officiel est ce que le président
biélorusse a vraiment souhaité une
investiture en catimini selon écouter
oui il me semble qu'une institue une
investiture de de ce genre normalement
c'est une grande fête tout le monde est
sur la place on agite des drapeaux c'est
un événement national
là manifestement il a fait ça un peu à
la sauvette la presse du monde entier
l'a remarqué y compris d'ailleurs la
presse russe
et c'est normal d'ailleurs en période de
crise de ce genre que ça se passe comme
ça à sa place
sur la période comment alors justement
cette intronisation en catimini discrète
est ce qu elle est nature à amplifier la
contestation dans le pays selon vous
plutôt à amplifier qu'autre chose
le camp quand nous avons le l'union
européenne qui ne reconnaît pas la
légitimité du nouveau président en fait
ça mais ça ajoute de l'eau au moulin de
ceux qui y compris d'ailleurs un moment
lukashenko mais il a un peu oublié ce
qu'il a dit lui-même qui prévoit un
changement de constitution de nouvelles
élections et donc dé facto un nouveau
gouvernement
donc en fait cet appel au changement
s'exprime de façon très différente par
des voies différentes et parfois pas
forcément du même avis mais tant du côté
de la russie que du côté de l'europe que
du côté de loukachenko dans ses
déclarations 10 à 15 jours tout le monde
reconnaît qu'il faut un changement de
régime
un changement de constitution c'est un
changement de régime alors l'union
européenne et les etats unis on le
disait on ne reconnaissent pas le cacher
au comme président il y à des sanctions
qui sont à l'étude
le chef d'état biélorusse aujourd'hui
lui craint davantage des sanctions de la
part de l'union européenne où il craint
davantage la contestation de la rue sur
vous les sanctions de l'union européenne
il en a déjà eu
puisque à chaque élection le même
scénario se reproduit à peu près cette
hausse il est beaucoup plus grave que la
dernière fois et donc l'union européenne
prend des sanctions et les dernières
sanctions ont été levées qu'en 2016 et
il en resterait encore quelques-unes je
crois mais dont kiel l'union européenne
va prendre des sanctions le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est plus caché qu il est
habitué à supposer que l'union
européenne les prennent puisque comme on
le sait ya certains états qui s'y
opposent dans chypre donc ce qu'il
craint surtout c'est la déstabilisation
de la rue alors justement vous l'évoquez
à l'instant il reste l'unanimité des
états membres de l'union européenne
soir utiliser et tous ne sont pas
d'accord
quels sont les divergences sur la
question alors le point essentiel mais
il y en a d'autres
c'est que chypre estime que en gros il
ya deux poids deux mesures c'est à dire
qu'on prend des sanctions contre la
biélorussie mais on n'en prend pas
contre la turquie qui est un peu un
sujet tabou et qui enfreint les eaux
territoriales chypriotes et grecs
donc ça c'est un premier point et puis
si je comprends bien mais ça mérite
d'être confirmée il ya des états qui se
cache derrière chypre
parce que par exemple on dit que la
suède aura bientôt le la présidence de
l'osce c est que l'eau est 6e pourrait
jouer un rôle de médiatrice envoyer une
mission et que donc la suède serait
intéressé à avoir ce rôle
alors du côté de la russie comment est
ce qu'on regarde ce dossier qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre
pour la russie la situation est
extrêmement embarrassantes
d'abord il est de notoriété publique que
les relations entre lukashenko et
poutine sont mauvaises depuis très
longtemps la biélorussie fait un peu
chantée la russie essayant d'obtenir des
avantages pétrolier financiers
commerciaux en échange de son soutien à
la russie et surtout à la construction
d'une union eurasiatique
donc il ya de l'agacement il y avait de
l'agacement il y en a encore mais la
russie est bien obligé de constater que
la biélorussie a été un des états
fondateurs de toutes les instances que
la russie a construite pour essayer de
de garder une zone d' influence dans la
région dans les anciennes républiques
duras est c'est à dire l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective ou bien le
union eurasiatique dont on parlait à
l'instant est donc fondamentalement la
biélorussie reste un allié
j'allais dire fondamental de la russie
donc laissé déstabiliser la
la ville rue si ça n'est pas possible
mais en même temps les russes
comprennent bien aussi que quand on a
tout ce monde là dans la rue et que en
général ce sont des jeunes et c'est
l'avenir du pays et notamment la classe
moyenne ceux qui sont employés dans les
industries techniques ou technologiques
et et donc il ya quand même une large
majorité du pays qui veut le départ de
loukachenko
c'est intéressant de voir d'ailleurs que
parmi les candidats qui voulait son
départ vous avez à la fois des pro russe
des pro-occidentaux des blogueurs enfin
si vous prenez les profils de baricco de
cette cale aux deux titres anoska etc
vous avez un gros seins d'une photo de
la quasi totalité de la population
pilori donc ça là les autorités russes
ne peuvent pas ne pas le remarquer le
prendre en compte
d'où les propositions qu'on a
semble-t-il plus ou moins suggéré à
moscou à loukachenko
c'est à dire de d'opérer en douceur un
changement de régime pour intégrer une
partie de cette jeunesse et ce
changement de régime c'est cette fameuse
proposition de nouvelle constitution et
de nouvelles élections
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty pour
votre décryptage rappelle que vous êtes
le directeur de recherche à l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques
ancien ambassadeur de russie et auteur
de géopolitique de la russie aux
éditions eyrolles